[Music]
[Applause]
should be something does it hurt that
well
you did do something we make them makes
me feel bad to look at that
when I was younger man Facebook back
then and face was something you tried
never to forget what a book was
something you read to your son my son
Jack stand up jack boy he's your man
leave
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. Mulligan
mr. Manning my age mine is my brother
Jeeter love you too
as a kid I used to help out with my
dad's campaign and I look a lot like
this except a little wider I imagine
yeah good night
please do my father always thought it
was a good idea to keep the lines of
communication open with his opponent
keep things honest dignified well maybe
he could be more honest and open about
whatever deal he made with the City
Council to call this special election
instead of waiting until February like
the law says he had to step down and he
had a heart attack
who does waiting serve everyone who's
not named well again first time I've run
for office I'm already ahead of you by
12 points in the polls
the Mulligan's around the 18th ward for
60 years my grandfather my father these
days it's all about name recognition and
you want to go against me you don't
inherit a ward check you run for it you
have much experience in government I
live here
so do I no no no you uh own a house one
block into the ward house people might
actually want to live in it's a smart
idea
running headquarters from a church I
mean it's illegal there's that whole
church and state thing more legal than
nepotism no nepotism is an illegal it's
actually celebrated this is Chicago
where your daddy can put you on some
Commission where people don't have no
sale it should be a big boy play with
your trains but standing the Green Line
is the best thing for the people of the
18th ward brings them closer to jobs
closer to culture those people don't
seem to be the ones getting rich no Jack
what about you Jamal what have you been
doing to improve the lives of the people
of Chicago I bet your reputation is a
real problem for your communications
team maybe you don't want to need the
communications team I've never been
arrested let's see if you can say that a
few months from now well if you pull out
now you can save yourself some money
kind of embarrassment calling Jack I
don't pull that when it feels this good
all right then we get the boat on August
8th hey absolutely Hey
the election is on the seventh Jack oh I
know
why want to go into politics anyway man
passing bills whatever they do ultimate
of this war makes on four thousand
dollars a year we made moan in a week
then you add in the juice right he gives
his friend a contract for a new building
because the kickback gives his brother a
contract for construction hell he gave
his momma contract for construction and
that man was a piece of everything and
all the people coming after him they got
cameras and microphones people coming
after us with guns I'm 37 years old you
Tim I don't want this left no more
I want his life Mary Rollings is dead
and we're not gonna do with us hey what
you took our money with him
medical examiner sake is still I did
take off the teeth maybe I always City
should burn in hell but hey Chicago will
do
foolishly not merely because of the
desirability of life because the same
exercise at once teaches us to live well
and to die well much worse as he who
says that it was good not to be born but
once one is born to pass with all speed
through the gates of Hades you are you
thought you say not one is it I promise
it was let's see it you don't want to
see his body
yes all men
I got a waiver akira now that happy
chorus la razón por aqui estoy aquí de
carlos de NOS Tucanos otros
Elsa mit uns a vida por su cuenta no
it's a polity and it's gonna Sierra
believe I eat allow me variously that
tiene su Sangram does memos you have no
idea do you
what did you choose not to know your
husband stole two million dollars for me
[Music]
this is about my life
[Music]
this is about my life
because it's about my life and that
becomes about yours
so don't happen I something bad
mr. Mulligan your family's been involved
in Harry's life for many years I need
help I don't see what I can do
our husbands aren't coming back
raaaah my husband left me the plans for
his next job
well honey it is cool to pull it off why
should we trust you anyway because I'm
the only one standing between you and a
bullet in your head
that's what I've learned through men
like your late husband and my father is
that you reap what you sow let's hope so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is for guns guns from where figure
it out
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it
I did something
[Music]
now the best thing we have going for is
is being who we are why because no one
thinks we had the balls to pull this off
[Music]
[Music]
you